so sansa will try to
come close to replicating what he did in
his last outing with that
complete game performance antonio get
one more start
before the regular season is over and
he'll face aj
and that's grabbed by mcmahon making
like
uh his buddy nolan arenado
good play by ryan playing his natural
position
here's the 3-2 and a swing and a miss
that's a beauty
there's uh there's the ability to spin
the baseball which is vastly improved
this year
and an early strike out of seeger rymel
tapia starting the rockies offense
against rookie right-hander tony
gonzalon two years ago
gonzalon was the dodgers minor league
pitcher of the year and he's been solid
here
another 2-2 got him swinging with the
slider one gone
now here's pilar back-to-back caves for
godzilla
so gonzalon begins his afternoon with a
pair of strikeouts
charlie blackman coming up 309 with six
home runs and he's knocked in
38. one two he strikes out this side in
the first inning
tony godzilla keeps on trucking now
here's bella
to heat up five game hitting streak and
a lot of damage against the rockies and
he drives one to deep left field tapia
going back
leaps at the wall can't come down with
it
big ricochet bellinger thinking three
the throw
is high but they get the tag down
and bellinger is out at third great tag
by story he had to leap
and catch the baseball and then apply
the tag what's amazing about this the
topia great effort
good job chasing it down story shortstop
usually you'll see a shortstop go out
there but based on the shift
this is his coverage of third base
that's not normal
and so far gonslim has made it look easy
trevor story who has been colorado's
hottest hitter
and story strikes out swinging
gonzalez's first four batters
have all gone down on strikes not want
to give fuentes anything too close to
the middle of the play this guy chases a
lot
and does here five up five down
on five strikeouts for tony gonzalez two
out nobody on and david dahl coming up
gonslin on oh and two here it comes
and down he goes six up six down
six strikeouts for gonzalon crowds
mckinstry in his
first start as a big leaguer pinch hit
opportunities a few times on this road
trip he's gone over three so far
one one mckinstry pokes one to left
sinking
base hit into the gap zach mckinstry has
a hit in the major leagues
back to second with a double
[Applause]
he does the barrels are overrated thing
he's been paying attention
cody ballinger pretends to throw the
ball into the stands which wouldn't be a
big deal this year anyways
this is the kind of hits we saw in
summer camp 2.0
he's really good at putting the ball in
play authenticator puts a sticker on it
and zach mckinstry has his first major
league hit
tony gonzalon's career high for
strikeouts in a game is
eight well he struck out the first six
in this game
the one-two hamson strikes out swinging
on a fastball
upstairs at 95 miles an hour
seven strikeouts through three for tony
gonzalon
back-to-back hits on back to back
pitches perfect once through the order
rocky's perfect second time through the
order gonzalon
fires check swing ball four and that
loads the bases
for josh fuentes one oh on fuentes
up the middle base hit that avoid josh
topia scores here comes pilar
bellinger's throw is not in time
two nothing colorado ryan making his
24th appearance
two on one out for fuentes add on some
more right here
and he will perhaps charlie's heading
home
pollux throw is online not in time
josh fuentes again three nothing
colorado
blake trident's gone with victor
gonzalez taking over
diaz with a base hit through the left
side story around third he'll score
easily
fuentes will go first to third elias
diaz coming through
four nothing rockies mcmahon bounces
this one in an awkward spot
and he's gonna have a base hit five
nothing colorado
el monte comes on with two on and one
out and he'll get
the hot-hitting will smith again the 2-2
line drive grab by mcmahon and the
runners
sprint back to second and first mcmahon
shaded towards the line at third made
the grab
for out number two senza loves it
up the rios with two gun line drive base
hit center field
muncie headed for the plate and the
dodgers on the board on a two out rbi
single from edwin rios as bellinger
comes up
suddenly the tying run at the plate in
the eighth inning 2-2
he's got him well done daniel bard
pollock looking to reach for the first
time keep the dodgers hopes alive on a
payoff pitch
pollock hits a ground ball towards the
middle through for a base hit two runs
are in to score
two run single aj pollock and it's 6-3
and now here's taylor representing the
tying
run in the ninth inning they just won't
go away
they are not holding seeger on he'll go
on the first
pitch and it's a bouncing ball up the
middle hampton's got it the first
in time for the game one
pitch and michael givens gets
the save